You might have noticed before you clicked
on this video that it is in fact about an
hour long, and that is because today, we are
going to give you a glimpse of what it’s
like to be one of our Patreon patrons.
Our supporters on Patreon are the reason this
channel can exist.
And when we say that at the end of our episodes,
it is not us being hyperbolic.
Each and every one of the people who work
on this amazing team of writers, editors,
producers, musicians, and more really do rely
on that support.
And over at patreon.com/journeytomicro, we’ve
got a couple of different tiers you can sign
up for, and with those tiers come rewards,
Our $8 a month patrons get a weekly hi-res
wallpaper they can use on their phone or desktop
computer, and they also get their name listed
in the credits at the end of every video.
But the other reward they get each month is
an hour long video of beautiful microscopic
footage, accompanied by Andrew Huang’s original
songs that he has created for this channel.
There’s no narration, it’s just the uncut
footage from the episodes we make,
along with Andrew’s songs.
And, that reward is not exclusive to our $8
patrons.
Our $2 a month patrons also have access to
the hour long uncut videos.
So whatever it is you’ve got to do today,
study, homework, hanging out with your cat,
we hope you get to relax and enjoy this unnarrated
hour of beautiful microscopic footage.
And if you want to be a part of helping this
channel continue to exist and get some fun
rewards along the way, please check out
Patreon.com/journeytomicro to sign up.
Thank you, and enjoy!